[Music]
we're looking at each division team by
team to see what they need to do in the
draft so we're also doing a draft of the
best players of that division all four
teams after the AFC East today the NFC
East Cowboys Eagles Washington and
Giants Chris has the trivia question if
I get it right when I get it right I'll
get the first pick all right hold on my
ear pods you know this is the new my ear
pod went out there so I'm just trying to
make sure I got it okay I'm good here we
go sorry about that let me unlock my
phone and here's the trivia who was the
last NFC east team to win the division
two years in a row man who was the last
team to win the division two years in a
row Michael Florio when you're on the
cloud yeah they've been bouncing around
a lot let me just throw a dart here and
say that it would be the New York Giants
absolutely not Wow no it's the Eagles
the 2001 2002 2003 2004 long that ladder
amazing 16 years since there's been a
repeat champion of the NFC East all
right you're next you're our first man
there's a lot of good in this division
this is actually a tough first pick here
but I'm gonna go with the quarterback
that I think's the best in the division
right now and Carson Wentz I'm gonna
make Carson Wentz my first pick I think
Carson Wentz again you know a really
talented player we saw last year I think
the whole world saw a little bit anybody
paying attention the NFL how talented he
is and what he did with the cast of
characters that were around him towards
the end of the season I mean it was
nobody's you and not you and me are
obsessed with the sport and live it and
we were going on Sundays going wait who
is this guy receiver who the hell is
this running back and they were still
winning games with Carson Wentz and he's
a phenomenal football player yes there's
a little injury history that's the only
negative you could say but he was for me
the 2017 NFL MVP
P and I think he's more he's definitely
one of the top 10 quarterbacks in
football not top 5 but I think he's in
that next group of guys Mike where
anywhere you could say anywhere between
6 & 9 has the best quarterback to the
sport right now you know it is amazing
with so much publicity so much
discussion so much focus that dak
Prescott gets because he's yet to get a
second contract he plays quarterback for
the Dallas Cowboys
you're right Carson Wentz has done more
with less and that turnaround late last
season which included a week 16 showdown
with the Cowboys a victory over the
Cowboys to vault the Eagles to the NFC
East title it does merit some extra
consideration for Carson Wentz so look
for me it was one of the other you
decided it for me by taking Wentz I'll
take that Prescott I still think he's
one of the better quarterbacks in the
NFL and when you look at how bad that
division is dak Prescott one of the few
players that stands out he hasn't gotten
that second contract yet he presumably
will unless he just wants so much the
Cowboys say screw it we'll have him for
two more years under the tag and then
let him walk away but he's done a lot
without a ton around him he didn't have
a lot from Ezekiel Elliott last year
apparently what he was used to we saw
the offense shift last year from being
run focused to pass focused and at one
point doc Prescott was on pace to have
over 5,000 yards I think he's still
finished with 4900 which is a huge year
when you consider the fact that this is
a team that was premise Don running the
football so dak Prescott III may have
taken him first if I had had the first
pick so we may be where we would have
been even if I had gotten the trivia
question right I agree with your case
for Carson Wentz but but there's just
something about dak Prescott Dallas
Cowboys that may I get your more sizzle
the team has more sizzle
yeah well it's very close I mean you
know I you know again I view dak
Prescott a lot of the same things I just
said about Carson Wentz really I mean
he's really talented
yes he's not in the top five
quarterbacks in football for me but he's
in that next group he's somewhere
between six and ten and yeah I think I
just I knew Carson Wentz maybe as a hair
more talent than the dak Prescott but
nonetheless doc Prescott is part of the
cream of the crop in the NFL at that
position
great leader and a quarterback that the
Cowboys can win a Super Bowl with for
sure
all right I'm staying with the Eagles I
can't help it but you know me Mike I
like big asses and big legs and Fletcher
Cox has got both of them all right but
your [ __ ] will be my second pick the
big nasty defensive tackle he just made
the all-decade team so that says a
little bit about what he is but this has
been one of the best defensive players
in football not named Aaron Donald for
really about the last four to five years
you know whatever you want him to do you
want him to plug the middle and stop the
run game no problem he could take double
teams and create a Bosch pit you wanted
to wreak havoc and get in the backfield
push the pocket to rush the past or
whatever it may be
Fletcher Cox is the number one weapon
for that Eagles defense and you saw last
year when he wasn't totally healthy they
weren't the same defense but he got
healthy towards the end of the year they
started dominating again that's what
kind of player he is I mean he's a Hall
of Fame defensive tackle at this point
of his career yeah you know he got
banged up in that playoff loss to the
Saints in the 2018 season and it carried
over into the county 19th season he he
fought through it but he wasn't as good
as he had been but it finally came
around for him and Fletcher Cox I agree
with you one of the best players not
just in his division but in all of the
NFL all right I'm gonna go with Zeek
even though Zeek had a down year by his
standards
he still had thirteen hundred and fifty
seven rushing yards and he started every
game for the first time in his career
average 4.5 yards per carry had 12
rushing touchdowns another two receiving
touchdowns a total of nearly 1,800 yards
from scrimmage and it's amazing it just
shows you how good he is the standard he
set that we feel like it was a down year
when he still had 1700 yards plus from
scrimmage so as he go well it's still
one of the finest players in all the
football and maybe going into this year
a little more of a motivated a little
more prepared a little more chip on the
shoulder trying to prove some of the
doubters wrong who saw a different Zeke
last year and look we saw a different
Zeke because it was a different Zeke
once he busted through into the second
level he didn't turn the
15-yard gains into 40 yard gains like he
had the exactly something you were all
over all year long and it was accurate
but he's still one of the best running
backs in the NFL and one of the best
players in his division yeah he's got
great value there's no doubt yeah I mean
listen I'm you know I think you and I
what were talking about Mazique we're
holding them to a standard you're the
highest-paid running back in football we
expect greatness and yes it was still a
really awesome good year but there was
some meat left on the bone on some of
those runs and you know as you and I
talked about a lot it's not about what
you got it was what was there to be had
and I just felt like there were some
runs with Zeke that yes he didn't
maximize I probably would have gone with
say Quan Barkley over Ezekiel Elliott
right now at the running back position
it's not gonna be my pickup though do it
no do it there's not gonna be my pick
it's not gonna be my pick I'm not gonna
be biased towards just the sexy skill
guys I'm going with a big mister big
nasty legs and butt legs in but say
graphically how can you not be exact one
Barclay he's got a lot of the legs and
butt of the football players
well because Zack Martin's got an
unbelievable derriere and legs too
that's why so yes I'm gonna go with Zack
Martin and Zack Barden you know a garden
football this has been the most dark
dominant guard in the game since he got
drafted out of Notre Dame he is
certainly the best player on that
Cowboys offensive line and what makes
them go but he's special and the fact
that you know he is a talented guy we're
all Fletcher Cox comes into town Aaron
Donald comes into town we don't need to
help out Zack Martin he can block them
by himself
he's that kind of talent yeah he's been
one of the best if not the best
offensive lineman in football the last
few years he's certainly in that
discussion and another guy that's you
know and on a Hall of Fame track and
wait Mike he made that all-decade team
too right am I wrong about that I'm
pretty sure he did do it yeah did so
yeah Zack Martin will be my final final
pick well you know I'm tempted to
complete the trifecta here like I'm
working a slot machine and I want that
amount of cowboy to go Decker Lawrence
now no no I'm
torn between three guys I'm thinking -
Marcus Lawrence but I'm thinking tamari
Cooper and and you know I'm still
puzzled by the Rex Ryan comments from
last Friday about Amari Cooper we Cooper
highlights constantly Amari Cooper has
every game some sort of a highlight
where he does something inhuman to get
open uh the guy's an incredible receiver
I'm gonna go say Quan you're leaving
seykora on the board you're trying to
play the Jedi mind trick on me by
mentioning say Quan and not taking him
sake want Barkley last year was banged
up all season long he had that horrible
ankle injury against Tampa Bay should
have missed a month and didn't and still
had a thousand rushing yards in 13 games
he set a standard as a rookie they'd
made last year feel like a
disappointment but we still got over
1,400 yards from scrimmage from say Quan
Barkley behind a crap offensive line all
due respect with a rookie quarterback so
say Quan barclays still a very very
special talent and the sky continues to
be the limit for him Chris yeah I mean
to me this is still one of the most
talented running backs and offensive
weapons in the sport and you're right he
banged up you know there was a rookie
quarterback quarterback change you know
no receiver to be scared of plus not
having a good offensive line you're
right I mean I think say quad Berkeley
is a really really special talent and in
that discussion for one of the best
running back to the sport it's
interesting you know with the with the
NFC East when you break it down Mike I
feel like a lot of my next picks were
gonna be linemen you know a lot of Dave
gentlemen and say hob Molly's in the
NFC's I mean trend Williams Brandon
Scherff Tyrone Smith Lane Johnson who's
probably the best right tackle in all of
football for the Philadelphia Eagles he
was in the discussion you know along
with you know Amari Cooper and say quad
Barkley as well but interesting to see
who the best players are and some of
these divisions I would have thrown the
challenge flag if you would try to go
Trent Williams he's trying to get out of
the division he's not gonna be in the
division I also was very impressed that
you properly pronounced a somewhat
complicated word like
we're very impressed you're coming right
you're learning you're growing youself
edited yourself earlier when you said
missile instead of blank missile very
impressive let's take a break one of the
most controversial rules from last
season is likely not going to be back a
shred of good news at another wise bleak
time for Humanity more pft live right
after this
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports